The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
In the reading
assignment for today,
you'll notice in the
textbook that the topic
is double integrals in
terms of polar coordinates.
Now, the trouble with
polar coordinates
is that, aside from
straight lines,
they're perhaps the only
coordinate system that we've
studied in terms of Euclidean
geometry in a high school
class.
And consequently, if we were
to have a change of variables
other than strict linear
changes of variables
or polar coordinates,
it might be
difficult to geometrically
try to determine
what the new double integral
looks like with respect
to the new variables.
The text, you may recall, when
you-- or not you may recall,
you haven't read it yet--
but when you read the text,
you'll notice at the end
that Professor Thomas says
there is a technique
called the Jacobian,
multiplying by the
Jacobian determinant,
that tells you how to
transfer a double integral
from x- and y-coordinates into
another coordinate system.
At any rate, with that
prolog as background,
our aim in today's
lecture is to show,
more generally, how
the Jacobian sneaks
into the study of
multiple integrals.
In particular, we call today's
lecture multiple integration
and the Jacobian.
And by way of review,
let me pick a problem
that we've solved in the
past in great detail,
but perhaps from a slightly
different perspective, that
will lead into where
the Jacobian matrix
and the Jacobian
determinant comes from.
Recall that when we wanted to
compute the definite integral 1
to 3 2x squared root
of x squared plus 1 dx,
we made the substitution
u equals x squared plus 1.
Or, inverting this, x
equals positive square root
of u minus 1.
And I emphasize the
positive to point out
that in general, the inverse
of a squaring function
is not one-to-one.
See, the square root is
usually double valued.
But notice that with the
restriction that x must be
on the interval from 1 through
3, x cannot be negative.
And therefore, we certainly
can assume that locally,
meaning in the
region in which we're
interested in, that x is the
positive square root of u
minus 1.
From this we saw
that du was 2x*dx.
We then went back to
this equation here.
We replaced 2x*dx
by its value du.
We replaced the square
root of x squared
plus 1 by the square root of u.
And then noticing that when
x equaled 1, u equaled 2
and when x equaled 3, u equaled
10, we wound up with the fact
that the number named by
this definite integral
was the same as the number
named by this definite integral.
Now the only thing that I'd
like to say here, as an aside,
is the following: there
is sometimes a tendency
to think of dx as just
being a symbol over here,
that we think of it
as saying all we want
is a function whose derivative
with respect to x is this.
And that other than that,
it makes no difference
what we put in here.
What I would like you
to see at this time
and-- to review at this time
because we know it happens--
is that if we made the
substitutions mentioned here,
forgetting about the
dx-- in other words,
if we replaced x by the
positive square root of u
minus 1, if we replace
x squared plus 1 by u,
and if we replace the
limits 1 to 3 by 2 to 10,
and then just tacked on the du
to indicate that we were doing
this problem with respect to u,
the resulting definite integral
would not be equivalent
to the original one.
That is not to say that
this couldn't be computed.
What I mean is this number is
incorrect if by this number
you mean the value of this
definite integral here.
And notice that from a
pictorial point of view,
all we're really saying is that
the integral 1 to 3 2x squared
root of x squared plus 1 dx is
the area of the region R, where
R is that region in the xy-plane
bounded between the lines
x equals 1, x equals
3, below by the x-axis,
and above by the curve
y equals 2x times
the square root of
x squared plus 1.
And I've simply put the
values of these endpoints
in here-- namely when x is
1, y is 2 square roots of 2,
when x is 3, y is 6
square roots of 10--
to give you sort
of an orientation
of this particular curve.
On the other hand, that other
integral that was incorrect--
integral from 2
to 10, et cetera--
is the area of
the region S where
S is the region that's obtained
by taking that integral
from 1 to 3 along the
x-axis, mapping it by u
equals x squared plus
1-- in other words,
it goes from 2 to 10.
And in fact, you don't
even have to know that.
All I'm saying is, if you just
read this thing mechanically,
in the yu-plane, this would
be the area of the region S
where S is bounded vertically
by the lines u equal 2
and u equal 10,
below by the u-axis
and above by the curve y
equals twice square root
u minus 1 square root of u.
And it should be
clear by inspection
that there is no
reason to expect
that the area of the
region R is the same
as the area of the region S even
though both R and S have areas.
Now, what the whole
geometrical impact
is on this technique
of integration,
techniques of integration, what
the whole geometric impact is
is this.
This is a difficult integral
to evaluate to find the area.
Hopefully, one
would hope that we
could find a way of
scaling an element of area
here to correspond to
an element of area here
which was easier to compute.
And that since the
mapping was one to one,
by adding up the appropriately
scaled pieces here,
we equivalently
add up the pieces
to find the area
of the region R.
Now, because I know that
sounds vague to you,
I am going to do that
in much more detail.
For the time being, let
me point out, though,
that if I want to view
this as a mapping,
the interesting thing is
that any point on the x-axis
maps into the corresponding
point on the u-axis
by the mapping what?
u equals x squared plus 1.
But it's important to point
out that the values of x and u
were not independent.
They were chosen to obey
the identity u equals
x squared plus 1, or x is
the positive square root
of u minus 1.
So what that means
geometrically is
that whatever height was
above a point in the region R
along the x-axis--
whatever height was here--
that height is the
same when that point is
moved to the region S.
Because that again sounds
like a difficult mouthful,
let me write that.
All I'm saying is, notice
that for the u corresponding
to a given x, 2x times the
square root of x squared plus 1
is equal to 2 times the
square root of u minus 1
times the square root of u.
How do I know that?
Well, I know that
because I picked x to be
the square root of u minus 1.
Or equivalently what? u
equals x squared plus 1.
This says that I can replace
x by the square root of u
minus 1.
This says I can replace
x squared plus 1 by u.
Consequently, as long as the
x matches with the image u,
this number is the
same as this number.
In other words again,
in terms of a picture,
if I start with the point
on the x-axis x equals 2
and I'm looking at the point P,
being the point on the region
R directly above x
equals 2, since 2
gets mapped into
5 by the mapping u
equals x squared plus
1-- see 2 squared
plus 1 is 5-- what was the
height that went with the point
2 over here?
The height that went with
the point 2 over here
was simply what?
4 square roots of 5.
And I claim that that's the same
as this, because when x was 2,
u is 5.
This is 2 square roots of 5.
5 minus 1 is 4.
Square root of 4 is 2.
This is 4, therefore-- 2
times 2-- 4 square roots of 5.
It makes no difference whether
your using the x or the u,
but that the point
keeps the same height.
It shifted laterally, but it
does not distort the height.
Which means, now, if we want
to view this not as a mapping
from xy-plane into the uy-plane
but more traditionally in terms
of the xy-plane into the
uv-plane, that's what
this v is in parentheses here.
It means that I might want to
name the y-axis the v-axis just
so that I can use my
identification established
in the previous
block in our course,
when we talked about mapping
the xy-plane into the uv-plane.
That is not an accent
mark over the v. That just
happens to be an interruption
of this arrow that
connects 2 to 5.
But at any rate, in
terms of mappings,
notice that the region R
is mapped onto the region S
by the mapping u equals x
squared plus 1 and v equals y.
In other words, u
equals x squared plus 1.
But the y-coordinate is the
same as the v-coordinate.
Just changing the
name of the axis
here to correspond
to the uv-plane.
And now, the idea
is simply this.
Since-- at least in
the domain that we're
interested in-- the mapping
u equals x squared plus 1,
v equals y maps R onto S
in a one-to-one manner,
each increment of
area delta A sub S
matches one and only
one delta A sub R.
Let me give you an example
of what I mean by this.
Let's suppose I start
with the region S
and let me arbitrarily
divide it up into a number--
the interval from 2 to 10--
into a number of pieces here.
Oh, I guess in the diagram
that I've used here,
I've divided this up into
four pieces, all right.
So I get these four
little rectangles.
An approximation for
the area of the region S
would be the sum of the areas
of these four rectangles.
What I'm saying is
that under our mapping,
these four regions induce four
mutually exclusive regions that
cover all of R. In
fact, since v equals
y, the way we do this
mechanically is-- for example,
let's focus on just one of
these little elements over here.
Let's suppose I want to find how
to match this shaded rectangle
with a suitable rectangle
of R. What I said
is whatever the
v-value is over here,
it must be the
same as the y-value
of the point that mapped
into this point on the axis.
In other words, if I
call this point here u_0,
that comes from some point
here which I'll call x_0.
See u_0 comes from x_0.
What must the height
above this point be?
Since the transformation does
not change the y-value at all,
since v equals y, what this
means is I can now draw a line
parallel to the u-axis
here, come over to here,
and that locates
where on the curve
I'm going to locate
the point x_0.
See, in other words,
I just come across
like this, either
of these two ways.
This is how I locate the
x_0 that matches the u_0.
I take its height, take that
same height over to this curve,
and project down.
Notice, of course,
that the delta x
that measures the difference
between these two points
on the x-axis is not the
same as the delta u that
measures the distance
between these two points.
But what I want you to see is
that these four rectangles here
induce four rectangles here.
And what I would
like to be able to do
is somehow be able,
hopefully, to find out
how to express a
typical rectangle here
as a scaled version of
one of these rectangles,
hoping that when I
then take the sum
the resulting summation
leads to an integral
which is easy to evaluate.
And before I get into
that, to show you
what does happen
here-- I think I'm
making this longer than it may
really seem-- but let me just
get onto the next step.
What I want to do next is to
blow up these two shaded areas,
so I can look at
them in more detail.
What I have is a region
which I'll call delta
A sub S in the
uv-plane and a delta
A sub R in the xy-plane, where
the mapping is, again, what?
u equals x squared
plus 1, v equals y.
This piece matches
with this piece.
All right.
Now, for small delta u,
notice that by definition
of derivative, delta
x divided by delta u
is approximately dx/du.
Consequently, I can say that
delta x is approximately dx/du
times du.
Now, the thing
that I really want
is not the area
of a piece of S, I
want a portion of the area
of R. I want delta A sub R.
Notice that delta A sub R
has as its height y sub 0
and as its width delta x.
Notice also that since
v sub 0 equals y sub 0--
see y equals v in this
transformation-- notice
that the area delta A_R
is v_0 times delta x.
OK.
We also know that delta x is
approximately dx/du times delta
u.
So making this
substitution, I see
that my little increment
of area in the region R
is precisely what?
It's v_0 times the replacement
for delta x, dx/du times
delta u.
Let me also notice that the
region delta A_S over here
has as its height v_0,
as its base delta u.
So the area of this
rectangle is v_0 delta u.
Let me, therefore, group
these two factors together,
rewrite this term
in this fashion,
noticing that v_0 delta u
is delta A sub S. And I now
have the very interesting
result that delta A sub R is not
delta A sub S. But the
correction factor is what?
It's dx/du multiplying
delta A sub S where,
for the sake of argument over
a small enough strip here,
let me assume that I've chosen
dx/du to be evaluated at u
equals u_0, say.
At any rate, what
we are saying is,
to find all of the
area of region R,
we want to add up all
of these delta A sub
R's as the maximum
delta x sub k goes to 0.
But from what we've just
seen, a typical delta A sub R
is a dx/du, evaluated
at u equals u_0,
times delta A sub
S. And therefore,
to find delta A sub R, this
limit is precisely the same
as this limit.
Now the point is that
delta A sub S is certainly
just as messy as delta
A sub R, in general.
It may also happened that
when I scale delta A sub
S by multiplying it by dx/du,
the result is even more messy
than the original expression.
But it's also
possible that dx/du
happens to be the
factor that wipes
out the nasty part of delta A
sub S. You see, what I'm saying
is, if there is a one-to-one
correspondence-- which there
is-- between the delta
A_S's and the delta A_R's,
if this expression here
happens to be convenient,
I can find this sum simply
by computing this sum.
And that's why, in
techniques of integration,
that's precisely
what we look for.
We look for the change of
variable, the substitution,
that makes this thing simplify.
And that's precisely
what happened
in this particular example.
Keep in mind that what
I've written down over here
is true for any substitution
where x is some function of u,
not just for x equals
u squared plus 1.
I could've done this any time.
But what I claim is
that if x weren't
equal to-- what was it-- the
square root of u minus 1,
this wouldn't have turned out
to be a very nice expression.
And you see, this is
going to be called
the one-dimensional
Jacobian later on.
This is the correction factor,
the scaling factor, you see.
Let's see how that worked out.
Notice that delta A sub
S was v_0 times delta u.
And notice that by definition
of what the curve looked
like in the uv-plane, v_0 is
twice the square root of u_0
minus 1 times the
square root of u_0.
On the other hand,
what is dx/du?
Since u is equal to
x squared plus 1,
it's easy to show that
dx/du is 1 over twice
the square root of u minus 1.
So in particular,
when u equals u_0,
dx/du is 1 over 2 square
root of u_0 minus 1.
Notice now, even though
delta A sub S is quite messy,
when I multiply it by this
particular scaling factor,
look at what that
scaling factor wipes out.
The 2 square root of u_0
minus 1 wipes this out.
All I have left is the square
root of u_0 times delta u.
When I form the definite
integral summing this thing up,
it's trivial, you see,
to see that that simply
comes out to be what?
The definite integral from
2 to 10 square root of u du.
And since this particular
sum was equal to A sub R,
that is the mapping
interpretation
of why the area of the
region R can be evaluated
by this particular integral.
Now, in a sense, all of
this has been review,
even though the pitch has
been slightly different.
Let me now generalize this
to a bona fide mapping
of two-dimensional space
into two-dimensional space.
And the reason I use
the word bona fide
is that when you say let
u equal x squared plus 1
and let v equal y,
you really haven't
got a general mapping
of two-dimensional space
into two-dimensional space.
You've essentially let
the y-axis remain fixed.
So let me talk about
something more general.
Let's suppose I have
an arbitrary region
R and an arbitrary
function f bar which maps R
onto S in a one-to-one manner.
By the way, notice,
the whole idea is this.
When I want the area
of the region R,
it's going to involve a dx*dy
inside the double integral.
When I want the area
of the region S,
that's what's going to involve
a delta u times delta v. Now
the reason that
delta u times delta v
is indeed a bona
fide element of area
when we're breaking up
S lies in the fact that,
in the uv-plane,
delta u times delta
v is the actual area of
an increment of area in S,
when we break up S by lines
parallel to the u and v axis.
On the other hand,
notice that if we
see what the line u equals
a constant comes from, back
in the xy-plane, u is
a function of x and y.
And to say that u of
x, y equals a constant
does not mean that you
have a straight line.
You could have some pretty
squiggly lines over here.
In other words, it might be
a very funny-looking line
that maps into a straight
line, a straight vertical line,
in the uv-plane with respect
to the mapping f bar.
And in a similar
way, the lines v
equal a constant--
the lines v equal
a constant-- in the xy-plane,
are read what? v of x, y
equals a constant.
That's a general
curve in the xy-plane.
What we're saying is that, since
this mapping is one to one,
when I break up this region
into elementary elements
of rectangles, that will
induce a breaking up
of this region into
little elements here.
But notice that the
resulting elements-- say
we take a piece like
this, and we see
where that piece comes from.
Let's say that that
particular piece
happened to come from here.
Say that that was the
one-to-one correspondence.
You can take delta u
times delta v here.
But notice that
delta u times delta v
simply means multiplying
two edges which
aren't straight lines,
which aren't necessarily
perpendicular, and
hence in no way
should represent what the area
of this little element here is.
The key point is we do not
want the area of the region S.
We want the area
of the region R.
And what we're
hoping that we can
do is that by making the
change of variables that
maps the region
R in the xy-plane
into the region S
in the uv-plane,
that we somehow find a
convenient way of scaling
an individual
element of area here
with respect to one here, and
define the area of this region
by adding up the
appropriate pieces here.
And, again, let me show you
what that means in terms
of just an enlargement again.
You see, in the same
as I did before,
let me take this little piece
over here and really blow it
up.
Let me take this
little piece that
is the back-map of
this-- in other words,
the piece that maps into
this-- let me blow that up.
And the idea is this.
If I pick delta u and
delta v sufficiently small,
notice that the area of the
back-map of delta A sub S
is approximately the
area of a parallelogram.
You see, come back
to this statement
after I've explained
the picture.
What I'm saying is I start with
an element of area delta A sub
S in the uv-plane.
You see, I pick its vertices.
I'll call them A bar,
B bar, D bar, C bar.
That's a little
rectangle over here.
Because the mapping
is one-to-one,
I know that there is one and
only one point in the xy-plane
that maps into A bar.
See that?
Let's call that
point A. There is
one and only one point in the
xy-plane that maps into B bar.
Let's call that B.
One and only one
point in the xy-plane
that maps into C bar.
Let's call that point C. And
let me leave the point D out
for a moment.
Now the idea is if we call the
coordinates of A bar u_0 comma
v_0, then because this is a
line parallel to the axis--
call this dimension delta u--
B bar is u_0 plus delta u comma
v_0.
C bar-- call this
dimension delta
v-- is u_0 comma v_0 plus
delta v. Now the point
is, there is no reason
why the image of B
bar-- namely the point B--
has to be on the line that
joins A parallel to the x-axis.
In other words, B is
up here someplace,
C is up here some place.
In other words, again, there's
no reason why these back-maps
give me a rectangle over here.
The point is that B
has some coordinates.
It's x_0 plus some
increment involving
x-- let me call that delta
x_1-- and its y-coordinate
is y_0 plus delta y_1.
C is the point x_0 plus some
increment delta x_2 comma
y_0 plus delta y_2.
And what I'm saying is
now, if I were to just look
at the parallelogram which had
AB and AC as adjacent sides,
it's very easy for me to find
the area of that parallelogram.
Namely, to find the area of a
parallelogram in vector form,
I just take the magnitude of
the cross-product of the two
vectors AB and AC.
You see, what's
wrong with this is
that that particular
parallelogram is not
the exact image of the
back-map of delta A_S.
Sure, A bar maps exactly
into A. C bar maps
exactly into C. B bar
maps exactly into B.
But the point is that these
points along A bar C bar
do not map into the straight
line from A to C, in general.
In other words, what
characterizes this?
This is characterized
by delta u equals 0.
And when u is written
in terms of x and y,
that doesn't say that
delta x or delta y is 0.
So, the true image
of this might be
what I've represented with
this dotted array here.
In other words, what the
true back-map of delta A is
is this dotted thing, where
D is now this vertex here.
You see, there's no guarantee
that the back-map of D bar
is going to be the fourth
vertex of this parallelogram.
But what the key
point is-- and this
is where that linearity
is so important--
is that if the transformation
is smooth enough, continuously
differentiable, then
what it does mean
is that as long as delta u and
delta v are sufficiently small,
the true area of
the region delta
A_R that we're looking
for is approximately
equal to the area of
this parallelogram.
And by approximately
equal, I mean what?
That the error goes to
0 as we take the limit
in forming the double sum.
In other words, again,
the key point is this.
The back-map of delta A
sub S yields delta A_R,
but that delta A_R
is approximately
this parallelogram.
And the area of
this parallelogram
is exactly the magnitude
of AB-- the vector
AB-- crossed with AC.
In other words,
the approximation
comes in because this is exactly
the area of the parallelogram.
But delta A sub R is only
approximately equal to the area
of the parallelogram.
At any rate, notice in
terms of i and j components,
how easy it is to
compute AB and AC.
You see, what are the components
of the vector from A to B?
The i component is delta x_1.
See, this minus this.
The j component is
this minus this, right.
In other words, AC has
what as its components?
It's this minus this,
namely delta x_2.
This minus this is
the y-component.
That's delta y_2.
In other words-- to
write this out so
you don't have to listen
to how fast I'm talking--
AB is this particular vector.
AC is this particular vector.
Remembering that when
we take a cross-product,
i crossed i is 0, j cross
j is 0, i cross j is k,
and j cross i is minus k.
Remember, for the
cross-product, we
can't change the
order of the terms
from the order in
which they appear.
We then determined what?
That AB cross AC is
delta x_1 delta y_2
minus delta x_2 delta y_1 times
the vector k, the unit vector
in the z direction.
Now, delta x_1 is
exactly-- see, remember,
we're looking at the
parallelogram, which
is a straight line.
If you want to think of it
in terms of the region R,
by differentials delta
x_1 would be what?
It's approximately the
partial of x with respect to u
times delta u plus the partial
of x with respect to v times
delta v. Similarly, delta
y_1 is y sub u times delta
u plus y sub v times delta v.
But now keep in mind where delta
x_1 and delta y_1 come from.
Delta x_1 and delta y_1
come from the back mapping
from A bar B bar back to AB.
And along A bar B bar, notice
that v is always equal to v_0.
So that means that delta v is 0.
That means, therefore,
that because delta v is 0,
delta x_1 and delta
y_1 are simply this.
See this drops out.
Similarly, delta
x_2 and delta y_2
come from the back-map
of A bar A bar.
Along A bar C bar,
u is equal to u_0.
So delta u is zero.
So writing this
out, these drop out.
And now, with these terms being
0, with these terms being 0,
I could very simply compute
the product delta x_1 delta
y_2 minus delta x_2 delta y_1.
And if I do that, you see, right
away what I obtain is what?
It's this times this.
I now, OK, collect
the terms here.
In other words, I want the delta
u and the delta v together.
The multiplier out
front here is x
sub u times y sub v. In a
similar way, delta x_2 times
delta y_1 is x sub v
y sub u times delta u
delta v. Therefore, putting that
into here, the magnitude of AB
cross AC is simply
this expression here,
noticing that the k vector drops
out because its magnitude is 1.
Notice that delta u times delta
v is precisely delta A sub S
and that x sub u
times y sub v minus x
sub v times y sub u is
precisely the determinant
of our old friend
the Jacobian matrix,
the Jacobian matrix of x
and y with respect to u
and v. In other words, delta
A sub R is approximately
equal to the determinant
of the Jacobian matrix of x
and y with respect to u
and v times delta A_S.
And if I now perform this double
sum, you see this becomes what?
The area of the region R-- just
write that in, that's really
the area of the region R-- is
a double integral over R dx*dy.
And that's the same as what?
The double integral over S times
du*dv multiplied by the scaling
factor of the
Jacobian determinant.
By the way, notice I dropped the
determinant symbol over here.
The reason for that is that many
textbooks, including our own,
use this notation not to name
the Jacobian matrix but to name
the Jacobian determinant.
I have been using this to
name the Jacobian matrix.
From this point on, I will
now switch to become uniform
with the text.
And unless otherwise
specified, I
will write this rather than
put the determinant symbol in.
From now on in our
course, when I write this
I am referring to the
Jacobian determinant, OK.
But the thing is this.
Notice that the given
mapping might straighten out
the region R into a
nicer-looking region
S. But to offset
this, it may also
turn out that the
resulting integrand here
is much worse than
the integrand here.
Here the multiplier of dx*dy was
the simple number 1, wasn't it?
Here, what's multiplying
du*dv, no matter how nice S is,
is this expression here,
which may be quite messy.
And therefore, in most
practical applications
where one solves
multiple integrals
by a change of
variable, one not only
wants a change of variables
that straightens out
the region into a
nicer-looking one,
he wants a combination
of two things.
He would like a
nicer-looking region.
And more importantly,
even if he can't
get a nicer-looking
region, at least
if he gets a correction factor,
a Jacobian determinant, that
gives him something
that's easy to integrate,
he'll settle for that.
And what that means,
hopefully, will become clearer
as we go through the exercises
and the reading material.
At any rate, I
think that's all I
want to say about a supplement
to Professor Thomas's
treatment of polar
coordinates at this time.
And until next time,
then, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabrielle
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.